good morning John so there's a new study
out in the journal of psycho
neuroendocrinology that I know you're
gonna be super excited about is Italy
they tested young people's bedtime
cortisol levels cortisol is a stress
hormone the amount of cortisol in your
blood goes up when you are stressed out
and it has all kinds of effects on your
physiology new psychology in your
behavior physiological effects can
include everything from like more acne
which is a bummer to heart disease and
death correlations it's not gonna kill
you it just increases your chances of
death aggression depression anxiety
difficulty staying focused difficulty
making decisions some people actually
make fewer decisions like they'll avoid
decisions when they have a lot of stress
and others make worse more impulsive
less rational decisions so that's
interesting some people in their stress
avoid the source of this dress others
seek out more of it if you listen to the
podcast I do with my wife delete this
you know that Katherine and I are
opposite sides of that spectrum anyway
this study not a super surprising but
they found that bedtime levels of
cortisol increased after the election
for people who didn't vote for Donald
Trump specifically young people and that
level went up more if you were a woman
or from what they called non-dominant
social groups so LGBT people people of
color that kind of thing I don't know if
I need to bring this up but the last
year has sort of felt like just a
constant barrage of upsetting or
confusing news every week it seems like
there's a new scandal a new fear a new
tragedy and all these things are
problems that need to be faced but if
there is no respite from the stress we
will make worse decisions we will not be
as healthy as we could be we will not be
as productive as we could be I don't
want you to think that I'm not okay I'm
okay but I have been looking for things
to provide me with respite I don't
actually definitely know what the word
respite means so let's look that up
period of rest or relief from something
difficult or unpleasant yeah so I asked
Twitter and Facebook if there were some
things that I maybe am missing out on
that are great and here's a list of some
sources of respite from other people and
from my own brain starting off with
space opera by Catherine Valenti finally
I feel like somebody had the chops and
the guts to not just understand the
genius of Douglas Adams but to maybe
even move beyond it in some
you want a book about glam rock in space
it's happening the horns of bavitz there
are a hundred and forty-three different
species of bovids which include cows
sheep goats antelopes and some other
good stuff and they have great horns the
marvelous mrs. mazey which is currently
a season of eight episodes on amazon
prime written by the creator the Gilmore
Girls and it makes me so happy
hello for the magic tavern is a podcast
produced by a guy who fell into a portal
behind a Burger King and interview
citizens of the magical land of foon and
it is always a wonderful break from all
this earth stuff Janet from the good
place I mean yeah the whole show but
mostly Janet whenever I think about that
character I smile this collaboration we
did on eons discussing the first-ever
organism with help from PBS FaceTime and
it's okay to be smart we got as close to
the bottom of this ultimate question of
where life began as we could get Elle
Mills always our news show nature league
which explores biology all biology
everywhere with my friend Britt and I'm
just learning and relaxing and getting
my curiosity satisfied this long long
man advertisement for some kind of weird
candy in Japan it's good ask a mortician
a YouTube channel about what happens to
people's parts after they die from a
person who does that professionally
Janelle Monae I feel like I'm late to
this party but every time I listen to
her music I feel better
Abbi norman's let me google that podcast
which covers everything from why we have
names to crossword puzzles to the
Titanic and it's always got every
morning new good information for me and
I'm always happy to have it
Orlick Gartland who's doing the
singer-songwriter thing so good and I'm
just so happy her music is in the world
and finally this three-second long video
of my baby's butt John I hope that this
list provides you and some other people
with some respite I'll see you on
Tuesday and now it's time for the
earthgrid God or write me an on-screen
song this one's not bad be good